on est dans la galère en ce moment sur
les carburants qu'on peut pas qu'on
trouve pas d'essence
alors d'abord on ne trouve pas d'essence
et il faut peut-être
dégonfler un peu le sujet c'est vrai que
c'est une situation préoccupante puisque
aujourd'hui on arrive à 15% de station
qui n'en plus j'en conclus qu'il y en a
85 qui en ont
ce qu'a dit le porte-parole gouvernement
et en partie vrai
le marché d'approvisionnement pétrolier
ça a marché qui se prévoit
plusieurs mois et d'un mois sur l'autre
il aime pas les surprises alors la
première surprise bon qui pouvait être
un peu anticipé mais qui n'a sans doute
pas été suffisamment anticipé c'est que
l'effet de la remise sur les carburants
en centimes gouverne sur fond public et
puis
comment dirais-je une surprise sur un
pétrolier ça a eu pour effet et on peut
pas le reprocher au consommateur un
engouement pour faire son plein c'est
vrai pour les professionnels c'est vrai
pour les automobilistes donc ça c'est le
premier acte et donc ça tend la
logistique alors ça veut dire quoi Satan
la logistique mais qu'en une
station-service
est assez rapidement il faut la
révolutionner pour ça il faut des
camions-citerne et des dépôts
ça c'est le premier le premier élément
mais à la limite ça aurait pu se passer
avec des tensions c'est à dire qu'il y
aurait quand même eu des stations en
panne mais moins longtemps que ce qu'on
observe désormais
l'autre phénomène c'est une grève assez
massive des sorties de produire
raffineries alors j'aime pas qu'on dise
des grèves des raffineries c'est juste
que les expéditions sont bloquées
pourquoi
et donc ce qui permet de dire que en
fait est-ce que c'est une pénurie
pas vraiment le produit il existe il est
juste dans des bacs qui refusent de
sortir le produit
mais au bout du bout ça donne cette
impression de pénurie parce que quand
vous faites deux stations à sec et que
la troisième
Île-de-France a une file à une fille
latente
oui je suis en pénurie et l'angoisse
commence et donc ça regardez les vidéos
de file regarder les vidéos regardez
hier
urgence c'est très dangereux regardez on
décompte c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable
et c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression qu'il
y a il y a un décalage entre la réalité
et ce qu'on nous dit et ce qu'on vient
nous expliquer excusez-moi monsieur
serré monsieur plan mais un Gilles il y
a des régions sinistrées l'Île-de-France
il y a plus une goutte d'essence et vous
vous nous dites oui je dégonfle un peu
le sujet c'est pas vraiment une pénurie
monsieur quand les consommateurs ne
peuvent plus aller au travail les
enfants ne peuvent plus aller à l'école
parce que le transport scolaire est
bloqué il y a une pénurie d'essence en
France pourquoi vous ne le reconnaissez
pas donc pour les dans votre sens mais
je vais même aller au-delà de ce que
vous dites il n'y a pas de région
épargnée en France il y a des régions
qui sont plus en difficulté parce que
elle dépendent de dépôts pétrolier qui
eux-mêmes ne sortent pas suffisamment de
produits mais je ne connais pas
d'endroits en France où il n'y a pas de
tension sur les produits donc c'est la
pénurie générale alors
c'est intéressant mais j'ai oublié mon
dictionnaire pour regarder la définition
de pénurie la pénurie regardez ce que
j'ai pour vous
Hanouna
continuer je m'occupe
donc on va on va pas avoir un débat
sémantique
ce qui est vrai ce qu'il y a de vrai et
je reprends les chiffres tout à fait
vérifiables y compris par vous-même il y
a un site gouvernemental qui répète qui
répertorie toutes les stations services
lesquelles mettre à jour leurs prix
pensaient que les prix bougent indiquent
les carburants qui viennent à être en
défaut qui indiquent et ce site qui
permet de collecter l'information d'une
façon objective indique que nous sommes
passés aujourd'hui à 15% de stations
services qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas de
produits à proposer
alors je reviens sur ce que j'ai je me
répète attendez
je le répète 15% de station de service
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas de carburant à
proposer c'est 85% qui en ont c'est pas
ça où vous avez où je vous rejoins c'est
que suivant les régions la proportion
n'est pas la même et donc cette
perception de manque et d'autant plus
forte dans les régions cité une mais il
y a le Grand Est mais il y a ouvert une
rognal qui est intérieur du pays en fait
on va dire l'inverse quels sont les
régions où ça va relativement bien et
bien c'est la façade atlantique plus
particulièrement Bretagne Pays de Loire
un peu de nouvelles Aquitaine et puis
ailleurs
pénurie manque de ce qui est nécessaire
à une collectivité situation période de
pénurie pénurie de blé pénurie de
pétrole carence défauts ils étaient
rareté pénurie de médicaments pénurie de
devises donc il n'y a aucun manque
s'il y a un manque c'est un manque il
n'y a aucun manque s'il y a un manque
c'est un manque de service de logistique
pour apporter les produits mais les
produits ne manquent pas d'accord c'est
ce qu'il est en train de dire
non seulement je le dis mais je crois
qu'en fait je le redis depuis deux fois
il y a de l'essence mon on arrive pas à
l'avoir il faut la trouver ça exactement
ça d'ailleurs si vous avez fait l'école
élémentaire ce dont je ne doute pas
vous rappellerez le principe des
baignoires qui se vident et qui se
remplissent c'est quoi ça
oui c'est ça
donc si votre débit de vidange de la
baignoire est plus importante que le
robinet qui l'approvisionne votre
baignoire finira par être à sec donc si
Damien prend son bain la question voilà
c'est tout ça la question de savoir mais
dans quelle situation serions-nous si
effectivement dans plusieurs semaines la
baignoire venait à être à sec voilà
c'est l'école élémentaire
[Musique]
la grève parce qu'il y a des salariés
qui demandent une augmentation de
salaire de 10% notamment chez Total et
chez Esso est-ce que la fin de cette
grève mais très fin à la pénurie ou
est-ce que malgré tout il y a un
problème d'anticipation et peu importe
la grève nous aurions eu à subir ce
problème donc je reprends le terme vous
posez une question en répétant pénurie
donc on en a des batteries
et pas de façon instantanée
en clair quand vous quand vous
réouvrez le robinet pour que le flux
soit suffisant et bien il faut quelques
jours pour qu'à la fin c'est-à-dire au
bout
de l'essence nécessaire en tout temps à
toute heure partout en France voilà il a
raison
merci mais économiser vous c'est un
Ori alors oui non mais c'est vrai non
mais c'est intéressant ce qui on l'a on
l'a mais on n'arrive pas à l'avoir c'est
ça mais c'est ce qui nous intéresse
[Musique]
je crains que ce soit un problème plus
généralisé que cela parce que quand vous
demandez trop à votre distributeur de
billets et un moment où il vous dites
vous avez dépassé ce
lieu de trop là nous on est encore dans
une affaire de baignoire et de Robin et
du coup vous prévoyez que ça va
l'américaine de la fin de la grève qui
bloque la sortie des produits en sortie
de raffinerie c'est pas des seules
sources approvisionnement j'y reviendrai
mais c'est la plus importante et donc
vous je dirais que ça s'améliore tout de
suite mais il faut presque une dizaine
de jours pour que l'ensemble de la
logistique d'approvisionnement des
stations services mais pas que ce n'est
pas que parce qu'on a beaucoup de
station-service que je voudrais dire
c'est que par exemple sur le marché du
gasoil il y en a un peu plus de 25% qui
ne passent pas par les stations services
qui vont directement approvisionner les
transporteurs publics les agriculteurs
les le BTP etc et cette bousculade
logistique créée par une remise
peut-être mal je reviens ma l'anticiper
contamine également la logistique de ces
mêmes produits donc on entend on entend
parler
si on rit c'est que vous faites des
grimaces
professionnels qui ont les mêmes
problématiques mais peut-être plus
importantes que celles des
automobilistes parce que eux c'est une
un usage quotidien permanent et qu'il
faut résoudre rapidement même les
automobilistes normaux lambda c'est un
usage permanent Storm je vous reprends
vous avez parlé d'engouement pour le
pour le faire le plein pourquoi
l'engouement de faire le plein
d'engouement de faire le plein
de stations qui sont il y a combien de
stations-service en France
on l'a enlevé parce qu'ils veulent
couper les arbres dans la rue je vais
payer 135 € de fourrière elle a la
fourrière ma voiture là j'ai reçu un
texto je l'ai garée dans une rue parce
que j'ai plus d'essence ils l'ont enlevé
parce qu'ils vont couper les armes 135 €
de fourrière donc là vous me dites il y
a 750 stations services alors pas
d'essence et pour vous tout va bien
c'est ceux du dizaine de jours faut
attendre la fin de la Grèce les gens
vont bosser comment minimum une dizaine
de jours c'est comment ne pas avoir dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de problème alors je
ne sais pas si j'ai utilisé le terme
engouement
[Musique]
de la TVA
la TICPE ce que vous voulez d'accord
c'est donc un premier signal de dire je
fais un effort en tant que pouvoir
public que je représente pas pour dire
j'aime moins de riz l'impact du prix
consommateur et que vous ne vouliez ou
non 2 € sur deux euros sur un
litre sur deux euros
donc une remise 30 centimes auquel c'est
sur Ajouter une promotion d'une marque
pétrolière assez connue pour que je n'ai
pas à la cité et et
et tout ça j'y reviens fatalement crée
un appel d'air raisonné raison non
simplement quand vous avez le plein de
votre voiture et même de votre véhicule
utilitaire à faire et vous vous situez
fin août et on vous a dit au 1er
septembre vous allez avoir 30 centimes
de réduction sur un prix qui par
ailleurs est impacté par des
considérations et des cotations
internationales bon bref quand on vous
dit ça et qu'en plus quelqu'un vous dit
et je rajoute 20 centimes de plus moi
vous attendez le début septembre pour le
faire c'est aussi simple que ça et c'est
pas terminé et quand on vous dit qu'au
surplus cette promotion je vais
l'appeler comme ça s'arrête fin octobre
et qu'au 1er novembre on en garde un
petit peu mais beaucoup moins et ben que
va-t-il se passer moi je vais bien
entendu comme tout le monde plutôt dire
bah tiens tant qu'à faire je vais faire
le plein c'est ça
alors ça va durer combien de temps cette
mascarade
je crois pas que ce soit une mascara
parce que il y a des gens qui ont plus
les mecs et donc alors
je crois l'avoir dit c'est-à-dire qu'il
est urgent il est urgent que les les
partenaires sociaux trouve de quoi enfin
trouve de quoi débloquer d'une façon
d'une autre la sortie des produits
raffinés en France qui n'attendent qu'à
être mis sur le marché j'ai également
dit que il faut mobiliser des
camions-citernes et pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur
on va raisonner linéaire la consommation
française d'essence et de gasoil or
maritimes aérien
c'est 130 000 m3 par jour
ça c'est flat alors évidemment des
parents en vacances il y en a plus
exactement il y en a moins
ça veut dire qu'il faut mobiliser plus
entre 3000 et 3500 camions citerne
pétrolier pour amener ses produits
jusqu'à destination et essentiellement
une station-service
donc une reprise de la normale ça
suppose une grosse mobilisation des
professionnels du transport
et c'est ce qui me fait dire et je le
redis je l'ai dit tout à l'heure que
c'est pas le lendemain ça s'améliore ça
s'améliore dès le lendemain mais
progressivement il faut compter à peu
près une dizaine de jours pour que pour
qu'on retrouve partout à n'importe
quelle heure dans n'importe quel endroit
du carburant parce qu'on se pose jamais
la question chez désolé de le dire
surtout dans un contexte qu'on nous
annonce de sobriété énergétique personne
ne se pose jamais plus la question de
savoir quand j'appuie sur un bouton
électrique évidemment que je dois avoir
de l'électricité ah bon par quel
évidence on va peut-être découvrir c'est
pas une évidence c'est vrai pour les
stations services mais enfin la station
service quelle que soit ses conditions
économiques y compris en réalité ou une
gagne pas d'argent il la maintiennent
parce qu'il y a un service apporté aux
consommateurs locaux des honorales on en
parle jamais évidemment se pose pas la
question c'est normal qu'il y en ait
n'importe quand n'importe quelle journée
voilà et le reste est insupportable et
bien non le reste
ça dépend du logistique ça dépend de la
baignoire du robinet